[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, so when we get to shore... Second of Wealsun, around 5pm, as Paul Rivero and Jude, with a detachment of marines, walk down the pier towards the home island quays.
[SPEAKER_00]: As an aside, is Gouge in the group that's going shore with us?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, he got off on the boats for the southern islands.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, the southern lighthouse.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so we're just looking to see, does anybody come out to meet us?
[SPEAKER_00]: Does anybody, as we approach, is there any more evidence?
[SPEAKER_00]: You know, because that's the most unusual thing is no ships and no patrols.
[SPEAKER_00]: So are we talking people-less as we... You guys walk down the pier.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And as you walk down the pier...
[SPEAKER_01]: Nobody is there, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And you don't see anybody on the stairs of the quake.
[SPEAKER_01]: The dock you're walking out, there's a stairwell that goes up into the upper area of the island, just right in front, maybe I would say 60 feet from where the dock ends.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is there a signal that we need to give to the captain of the ship to let him know?
[SPEAKER_00]: Because he had said if there's no harbor master that comes out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, he's right there and can see you.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, he's maybe 300 feet away from you on the boat, and you assume that the sergeant is going to be doing that.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, again, are you beside the sergeant?
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you behind the troops?
[SPEAKER_01]: Beside the sergeant.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to pull him away a little bit.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I want to be like, look, I don't want to step all over your command.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, no, I mean, okay, where's the sergeant?
[SPEAKER_02]: He's basically leading the troops.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, but I pull him aside.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll be right behind him.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, no, no, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's like marching order.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm saying I pull you aside real quickly, like, while we pause, while we're waiting for, like, a dockmaster that doesn't come.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I just pull you, like, you know, ten feet to the side, and I just kind of lowly say, I think the crossbowmen need to be, like...
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like, quarrels.
[SPEAKER_00]: Seated.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because this has now reached a whole new level of potential bullshit.
[SPEAKER_00]: We have no harbor masters.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is this harbor just empty?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's like nothing?
[SPEAKER_02]: Dead quiet?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's dead quiet.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, I'd like you to at least tell them, you know... Tell the sergeant.
[SPEAKER_02]: Tell the sergeant.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because we're still gonna have to proceed.
[SPEAKER_00]: Which I would like to suggest we proceed as if we are walking into an ambush.
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't have to tell him that.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can tell him if you want to.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think it should still come from you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you guys are reaching the end of the dock, marching in a column, you being next to Jude and this other guy, the sergeant.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I'm going to tell the sergeant to ready his crossbow.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ready your crossbow squad, please.
[SPEAKER_02]: You say that to the sergeant?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: He looks at you and goes,
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, sir.
[SPEAKER_01]: Halt!
[SPEAKER_02]: The mid-stop.
[SPEAKER_01]: At the edge of the docks, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: She's fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, crossbow and arm!
[SPEAKER_01]: They began loading up their thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm looking at any of our- Do we need to create a shield wall, sir?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's just keep moving.
[SPEAKER_01]: To the quay?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: To the stairs?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: To the stairs.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: But let's be ready.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right, so you guys began... Maybe we should send the guy back to tell him that there is no harbormaster?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, he was... That's what I had already asked the DM, and the DM said, like, you know, the captain can see us.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, he can see us.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the captain even said, if there's no harbormaster... Just keep going.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's like next level problem.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: But we need to be ready to... Do shit.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, so you guys begin moving forward, marching forward with the thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: The crossbowmen load up their weapons before you guys proceed.
[SPEAKER_00]: Since I actually don't see, see, I was worried that maybe some of the, any infantry on the helm might be, actually, I don't need to, this is just metagaming.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll have my wand out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, so, Jude readies his wand.
[SPEAKER_01]: What are you going to do?
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean,
[SPEAKER_02]: My knife's already sheathed.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm not going to whip it out, but you know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, do you want to load your crossbow?
[SPEAKER_01]: Is the crossbow and load theirs?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you pull out your crossbow and put a coral in it and a bolt in it and begin walking.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll perception.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm keeping an eye on those hard points.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: It says I have expertise in perception right here.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what that means is that your perception
[SPEAKER_00]: I think it means it's just doubled this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, so your perception, what that means is... Four?
[SPEAKER_01]: I need, we need, I need that, the pencil.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, the pencil, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: What that means is, this is here, and this was not marked, so that needs to be marked.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sorry, it's a plus four.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's plus two, because of your wisdom, plus four more, so that's plus six.
[SPEAKER_00]: So the expertise just allows you to double that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Correct.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I mean, that becomes really serious as you go up levels.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_02]: Four.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ten.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You rolled.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ten's still not bad.
[SPEAKER_02]: Breaks even.
[SPEAKER_00]: And we're talking perception?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: I have plus three.
[SPEAKER_02]: Same.
[SPEAKER_02]: Four.
[SPEAKER_02]: Even worse than yours.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I got a four.
[SPEAKER_02]: I know.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hey, Kate.
[SPEAKER_02]: How are you?
[SPEAKER_02]: Good.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hey, Mom.
[SPEAKER_00]: How you doing?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm good.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you guys are marching forward, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let me know if I see a barricade, doors that are closed, like if there's like at the top of the stair.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because they don't want to walk like, you know, right into
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's walk down this hallway with all these doors left.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, what might obviously be like, you know, murder holes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Which I assume that there's gonna be some part of that anyways with arrow slips from the tower, even if I don't see dudes on the very top top.
[SPEAKER_00]: Murder holes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Crossbow bolts, fire out from the hard points that you're at.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you're the roll.
[SPEAKER_02]: All crap.
[SPEAKER_01]: Actually, the men in the front, even though the bolts are shooting at them, take no damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: They have their shields out, and luckily the arrows stick in the shields or are deflected by their scale nail, luckily.
[SPEAKER_01]: You hear a shout.
[SPEAKER_01]: From?
[SPEAKER_01]: From, in front of you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And all of a sudden, men start to appear on the hardpoints up there.
[SPEAKER_01]: And also, what looks to be like a unit begins to march down towards the stairs.
[SPEAKER_01]: A unit of men.
[SPEAKER_01]: Rolling it.
[SPEAKER_01]: And here we go.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hang on a second, let me do something.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's not good.
[SPEAKER_02]: Two.
[SPEAKER_02]: You rolled a two.
[SPEAKER_02]: With a plus four, so... One.
[SPEAKER_00]: One.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_00]: Dad, you're horrible.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's true.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're worse than me.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've been following you.
[SPEAKER_00]: You rolled a four, I rolled a four.
[SPEAKER_00]: You rolled a two, I rolled a one.
[SPEAKER_02]: You've done worse than me at every turn.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just next time, let me roll first.
[SPEAKER_02]: I got a four.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you want me to get some blank paper?
[SPEAKER_02]: I got six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you have any tape?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that good?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, that's good.
[SPEAKER_01]: But then also we should probably put, well, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think that's fine actually.
[SPEAKER_00]: So we're right here?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're right here.
[SPEAKER_01]: So this is the sergeant.
Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Marine, Marine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nine, and then these guys are the archers.
[SPEAKER_01]: Here's Paul.
[SPEAKER_01]: Here's Jude.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so initiative.
[SPEAKER_01]: Paul gets one.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, you got two.
[SPEAKER_01]: I got two.
[SPEAKER_00]: Plus whatever your dex is.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Six now, because you have a plus four, so that's six.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, six.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I have four, five.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, roll for the sergeant.
[SPEAKER_00]: Four, six.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe you should get your metal dice.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe I should get my metal dice.
[SPEAKER_00]: Put those dice in dice jail.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, I'll roll for your enemies.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't want to see...
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't want to say it's going to be anything better than what we got.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's okay, we're saving ours for hit points.
[SPEAKER_00]: We didn't lose any men on the first ambush, so... You know we didn't.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now you're saying that there's a unit of men coming down?
[SPEAKER_01]: A unit of guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: Actually, basically they come into view at the top of the stairs, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Are they obviously still in motion as you list them, or are they stopping to hold the top of the stairs?
[SPEAKER_01]: So, they stop there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, and is each hex five feet?
[SPEAKER_01]: Each hex is five feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: They stop there, hold that area, and those guys are at this point doing what's called a dodge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which means that all attacks on them are going to be a disadvantage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: What's the H been for?
[SPEAKER_01]: You'll find out.
That's the start of the job.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm not a Siege Master, bro.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're the highest ranking dweeb in the group.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, Jude.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_01]: A one means that Paul gets hit or attacked.
[SPEAKER_01]: A two means that Jude gets hit or attacked.
[SPEAKER_00]: On any of the sixes?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And there are going to be ten bolts that come down on you guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, that's nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: Actually, there are going to be six that come from this way.
[SPEAKER_01]: One is you, A, two is Jude.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: One.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it will be two on Jude and one on you.
[SPEAKER_01]: What's your AC?
[SPEAKER_01]: 16.
[SPEAKER_01]: Five.
[SPEAKER_01]: The arrow goes over your head.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jude, here's two on you.
[SPEAKER_01]: What's your AC?
[SPEAKER_01]: AC is going to be no armor plus 4.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's 14.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's put that down.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you let me know if I'm going to get hit because I'll probably shield.
[SPEAKER_01]: Here are the two.
[SPEAKER_00]: That would be a hit.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I'll go ahead and shield that one.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you use your ring.
[SPEAKER_01]: Go ahead and mark.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just ring one thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, crossword in from here and here and actually underneath, inside, wherever the side there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Six guys shoot in your direction.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's gonna be two, three, two on the sergeant and one on that guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: So here's on the sergeant.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thirteen is a hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: This ain't healthy, Sarge.
[SPEAKER_02]: He takes six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Seven points of damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Does it drop him?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: If it did, then he's a weak Marine.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, dude, just be ready.
[SPEAKER_00]: A lot of guys are gonna be, like, twenty hit points is a lot of hit points.
[SPEAKER_01]: On that guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fourteen, that is a hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that does...
[SPEAKER_01]: Even with a shield?
[SPEAKER_00]: Because he's a shield guy?
[SPEAKER_00]: 14.
[SPEAKER_01]: Scale with shield?
[SPEAKER_01]: That's plus 3 for the guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that's 17 total.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let me look at that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, that's a hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he takes 8, 9 points of damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Does he drop?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll call him a 1.
[SPEAKER_01]: 34.
[SPEAKER_02]: 5, 6.
[SPEAKER_01]: Two on each of these three guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: Actually, one, two, three.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm gonna do two on each of those guys.
[SPEAKER_02]: Clear the rolls.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's the first guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's the second guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's the third guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, bolts fire out, and all of those guys basically take it on their shields.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Badass.
[SPEAKER_01]: The initiative is such...
[SPEAKER_01]: Don't Sarge and group go before us?
[SPEAKER_01]: Paul has the ability to go first.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Damn.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now remember, you can move 30 feet and then do whatever else you want.
[SPEAKER_01]: How much is each of these?
[SPEAKER_01]: Five.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you can move six.
[SPEAKER_02]: Five, 10, 15, 20.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ah, that doesn't get me close enough.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's nowhere for me to go and hide.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, you can dash, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: You can do double.
[SPEAKER_01]: With an action, go to there, and then these guys probably couldn't see you.
[SPEAKER_01]: These guys would not be able to see you.
[SPEAKER_01]: These guys would be able to see you.
[SPEAKER_01]: You wouldn't be able to hide, but they could fire down on you.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, you get to a place which you somewhat cover from these other people.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then you have bonus action.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know what you could do is you could bonus action dash and then dodge or attack.
[SPEAKER_00]: He can bonus action?
[SPEAKER_01]: He's got what's called cunning action where he can use a bonus action to either hide, dodge, or disengage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, so then he couldn't attack if he does his bonus action?
[SPEAKER_01]: He uses his bonus action to dash and then he has his attack to be able to attack still.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or he could dodge, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: I only got 22 hit points.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that means I could probably take three arrows if I'm lucky.
[SPEAKER_02]: The question is if I'm safer behind the Marines or if I'm safer out of the line of fire.
[SPEAKER_00]: Safer is not the question you should be saying.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's just what do you want to do.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know, but okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm weak.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, no, don't look at it like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: How does Paul want to respond?
[SPEAKER_01]: It would not be strange if Paul actually tried to get behind the sergeant and basically say, you know, make a shield wall or something like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, right.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what I'm thinking.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not saying you should charge.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm just saying... No, I don't think I want to.
[SPEAKER_00]: Don't make a decision based off of weak or not.
[SPEAKER_00]: Make a decision off of Paul, smart move, not so smart move.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's what I'm trying to think.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I don't know how smart of a move it is to run forward.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to move myself behind a marine and I'm going to say shield wall.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, do you want to like go back up one two to here?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because you can still shoot your crossbow.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then I want to shoot my crossbow.
[SPEAKER_01]: And actually, if you want to, you can go under the dock.
[SPEAKER_01]: Under the dock.
[SPEAKER_01]: And hide in the sand.
[SPEAKER_01]: Go prone in the sand if you want to do that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, let me move right there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you going prone in the sand?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to go prone and I'm going to shoot my crossbow.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you run to here and go under the dog, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, do you want to do your bonus action stealth and hide?
[SPEAKER_02]: I want to shoot my crossbow.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, you can do both.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have the bonus action where you can stealth, so you run underneath the dog and like go stealth.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then yeah, let's do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because then you can, can he, with a crossbow, can he try to, I don't know, backstab or assassinate or whatever?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, if he has a...
[SPEAKER_01]: If the enemy can't see him, he's got advantage on the attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, then it's attacking from hidden.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you run into the dock and hide there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: And then roll your stealth to see how high it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you yell shield ball or no?
[SPEAKER_01]: I do.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm hoping the sergeant will just take that.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm hoping he's just not a brain dead sergeant that listens to everything on.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know, we have prepped a lot.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the sergeant didn't go down, but he did get hit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Stealth is what?
[SPEAKER_02]: Dexterity?
[SPEAKER_01]: Stealth is stealth, down there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, dexterity, so it's plus six.
[SPEAKER_01]: So 12, 18 total.
[SPEAKER_01]: So Paul gets an 18.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if somebody does not have a passive perception of 18, they can't see you.
[SPEAKER_01]: If they do, they can see you.
[SPEAKER_01]: If they try to look for you, they can roll their perception above an 18 and see you.
[SPEAKER_01]: But effectively right now, you hide underneath the dock like that, and you have your crossbow out, and you can fire if you wish.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you fire, whether you hit or miss, they know you're in that location.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so they'll be able to fire on you, but if they can't see you, they get disadvantage in their attack rolls.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I'm gonna shoot him a crossbow.
[SPEAKER_01]: At who?
[SPEAKER_01]: Does he get advantage firing from cover?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: If he cannot be seen, he gets advantage on attacking enemies.
[SPEAKER_02]: One of the guys up here he goes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so these guys have a plus two on their AC because they are...
[SPEAKER_01]: Behind battlements.
[SPEAKER_00]: Behind battlements.
[SPEAKER_00]: Partial cover.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, halfway cover.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you basically take up your...
[SPEAKER_01]: Mike Crossbow, and you fire at which one?
[SPEAKER_01]: This one?
[SPEAKER_01]: That one?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: The closest one.
[SPEAKER_00]: But if he has advantage, that's a 2d20, you pick the highest.
[SPEAKER_01]: He rolls 2d20 and he takes the highest.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ready?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: An eight and a... That was...hold on.
[SPEAKER_01]: An eight and a one.
[SPEAKER_01]: So an eight plus your bonus with a white crossbow, which is plus six, is a fourteen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Might.
[SPEAKER_01]: Depends.
[SPEAKER_01]: That actually is a hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And let me see something.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'm gonna check
[SPEAKER_00]: I released my fey toad.
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're a toad?
[SPEAKER_02]: I have a toad.
[SPEAKER_02]: Why do you have a toad?
[SPEAKER_00]: Back in the old school days, you didn't get to choose what it was that your familiar was.
[SPEAKER_02]: Really?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he had me roll and it was a toad.
[SPEAKER_02]: What were the other options?
[SPEAKER_00]: Anything that was better?
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, I think there might have been a couple things that were worse.
[SPEAKER_02]: But not much.
[SPEAKER_02]: You got me the worst thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, it was just, it's not fast, it doesn't fly, it can't really fight.
[SPEAKER_02]: He knows.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so if you want to... Would you name it?
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't even know that I named it.
[SPEAKER_01]: You should name it.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you want to, you can use your sneak attack for this round to do an extra two die six in damage because you had advantage on this roll.
[SPEAKER_01]: May as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you get to roll a one die eight plus two die six.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So 1 die 8 and 2 die 6.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can run and roll them all together.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that does 12 points of damage plus your 4, which is a total of 16.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: So you hit this guy, who I'm going to designate as A1, and he goes down.
[SPEAKER_01]: In the face.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's awesome.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: The other dudes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do they get any extra benefit in armor if they get the shield wall up?
[SPEAKER_01]: I think it had better AC.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's what I meant, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, is it better than them individually?
[SPEAKER_01]: So basically, a shield wall means you're dodging.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he's there.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy moves to here.
[SPEAKER_02]: This guy moves to here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Glad we didn't just post up all 250 Marines.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, well, no, we're gonna need the rest.
[SPEAKER_00]: What I'm glad is we actually have Mofo Gouge on the... Gouge is dead.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, he's not dead.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I don't know who Gouge is.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know you don't.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm just saying.
[SPEAKER_02]: To you as my son... Is he some crazy nutjob?
[SPEAKER_02]: He is a total crazy nutjob.
[SPEAKER_02]: And apparently he has some crazy nutjob henchmen.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys go, like, way back, like, to the dawn of this... Oh, no, it's Garrett.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's Garrett.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, who I went to high school with?
[SPEAKER_00]: So he used to play with us?
[SPEAKER_00]: How's he Marine?
[SPEAKER_00]: That's okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't know Couch.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are the A's crossbowmen?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So they fall into well-practiced hardcore.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically, these guys are dodging.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And they're the front line.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the crossbowmen are going to shoot.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_01]: These three crossbowmen fire over here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who wants to do the roll?
[SPEAKER_00]: And we have 10 and 10, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: 10 in scale, 10 in... 10 in scale, 10 in studded leather.
[SPEAKER_01]: You roll for these three guys, and they're gonna fire two on that guy, one on that guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, do the first one.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let me see the range.
[SPEAKER_01]: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15.
[SPEAKER_01]: 15, that is 90 feet, and a light crossbow has a range of 80 and 320.
[SPEAKER_01]: I do not know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh wait, these guys have heavy crossbows.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so they are in short range.
[SPEAKER_01]: And they're ready.
[SPEAKER_01]: They are in short range.
[SPEAKER_00]: Give me five jewels, they're ready.
[SPEAKER_01]: So this guy has an AC of 16, and you have to roll a, with these guys, these guys have a plus, I believe they have a plus three.
[SPEAKER_02]: So 13 or higher.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_02]: So two on this guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want me to roll all three?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, just two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll the first two on this guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Seventeen, hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Both hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: So they do one die ten plus one.
[SPEAKER_01]: So roll two die ten and add one to each one.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, what?
[SPEAKER_01]: You get these two, that's the damage, and then plus two.
[SPEAKER_02]: 11, 13.
[SPEAKER_01]: And this guy will be B1.
[SPEAKER_02]: And that's 13 points of damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can barely see.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I know.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's horrible.
[SPEAKER_01]: If we were on the... That's 13.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, do the attack on that guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Two.
[SPEAKER_02]: Again?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, just one.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Five, miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jude, you go ahead and do these three firing up at... That guy's gone.
[SPEAKER_00]: Am I going to just... Oh, okay, so...
[SPEAKER_01]: Probably at that guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: One at that guy and two at that guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Miss, miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then one last one, four, miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: Dude!
[SPEAKER_02]: Dude!
[SPEAKER_02]: Ones and fours for you, bro.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so volley exchanged.
[SPEAKER_01]: The guys basically get into position.
[SPEAKER_01]: Me?
[SPEAKER_01]: You.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, I am 65 feet away.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going to do wall of fire, which is 20 feet deep, and it's only 65 feet to this.
[SPEAKER_00]: I am straight up going to engulf these guys to roughly about right here to about right here in a wall of fire.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's 20 feet deep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, do you want to move at all, or are you going to stay where you are?
[SPEAKER_01]: Where am I at?
[SPEAKER_01]: Right here.
[SPEAKER_00]: I won't move.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Unless I have to.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, Jude basically says, Wall of Flames, and it's how far?
[SPEAKER_01]: 60 feet?
[SPEAKER_00]: So it's, wait, let me see the book.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just double check.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think I have 20, I think I have 120 feet, I believe, for Wall of Fire, and it's only about 65.
[SPEAKER_00]: So 5, 10, 15, 20, 25, 30, 35, 40, 45, 50, 55, 60, 65, and it's 20 feet deep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, it affects 20 feet deep.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, it affects 20 feet deep.
[SPEAKER_00]: But the length is like what, 60 feet deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep
[SPEAKER_00]: Or a ring up to 20 feet in diameter.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so maybe I don't want to do a wall.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe I want to... You could still do a wall of fire and totally just... Well, if you want to put it around... 20 feet high.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is one, two, three, four.
[SPEAKER_01]: You could totally engulf them like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I totally would.
[SPEAKER_01]: But read what the damage does.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: When the wall appears, each creature within its area must make a dexterity saving throw.
[SPEAKER_00]: On a failed save, the creature takes 5d8 fire damage, or half as much on a successful save.
[SPEAKER_00]: One side of the wall selected by you when you cast, the spell deals 5d8 fire damage to each creature that ends
[SPEAKER_00]: It's turned within ten feet, and each one of those is five.
[SPEAKER_00]: Up that side, a creature takes the same damage when it enters, and the duration is up to one minute.
[SPEAKER_00]: So yeah, so I can totally basically just flame the shit out of that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Napalm strike, dude.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, if you want to encircle them, you can do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I want to burn them all.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or do you want to make it just a straight line?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I want to burn them all.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So if I have to like loop it back in like a tight circle?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, you can do it where it's tighter.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, it doesn't have to be 20 feet in diameter.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is each one of these one dude?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: So it's one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, seven guys?
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's more like eight.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eight.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to take care of all eight.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So basically you want to do a fire loop inside them like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And if they're within how far?
[SPEAKER_01]: 15 feet?
[SPEAKER_00]: When the wall appears, each creature within its area must make a dexterity saver throw on a failed save on one side of the wall.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let me read that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, sorry.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, what have we figured out?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so this is the deal.
[SPEAKER_01]: When you cast the spell, the area of effect has to be the one foot thickness, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Next turn, if a creature ends its turn within ten feet of the side of the wall that's burning, they take five die eight.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so can I put it in such that I get this guy, this guy, this guy, this guy, this guy?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, basically you just make it a straight wall like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the first 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 will be affected.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then if anybody's next turn is within 10 feet of that, they will get burned.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like if they don't flee immediately.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you want to make it just a straight wall 60 feet?
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh...
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, because I don't want them to be able to flank.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, one, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically from here...
[SPEAKER_01]: To here is where you're going to put the wall, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you cast the spell, and it does five die, eight?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, and they have to... Oh, do you have eight-sided, Jay?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, I do.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'll take any eights that you've got.
[SPEAKER_01]: And here are their saving throws.
[SPEAKER_01]: What's your save DC?
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, yeah, two of them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is it a 16?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, wait, here's three.
[SPEAKER_00]: Shoot, where is my save DC?
[SPEAKER_00]: I know you wrote it down, and I do believe it is 16.
[SPEAKER_01]: And is the save a con check?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, it's a dex check, I believe.
[SPEAKER_00]: Dex check.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And this is your DC for the save.
[SPEAKER_01]: 16.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: They get a plus one, and there are five guys in this.
[SPEAKER_01]: So they get a plus one.
[SPEAKER_01]: If they roll a 15, they make their save.
[SPEAKER_00]: And they take half.
[SPEAKER_01]: And they take half.
[SPEAKER_01]: So one guy, two guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: Two guys make their saves.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And we're going to do it like this.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we're going to say these two guys on the edge make their saves.
[SPEAKER_00]: So roll damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I have, it's 5d8?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so that guy takes, and actually, since this is so many, this is the damage for everybody.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so let's do, that's 10, 17, 25.
[SPEAKER_01]: 25.
[SPEAKER_01]: So those guys take 12, and those guys take 25.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So these three guys die.
[SPEAKER_01]: Burned up.
[SPEAKER_01]: And these guys, and we'll make this C1 and D1, have 12 off them.
[SPEAKER_01]: I hope you saw that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Actually, I think everybody saw it.
[SPEAKER_00]: And in fact, the disadvantage of doing that, however we did kind of get ambushed, and I'm trying to put a lot out, the disadvantage of doing that early is that if they have a mage... Now we're for sure, they've got to be in the lead.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, now everybody knows I'm with the group.
[SPEAKER_01]: That was my move.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you don't want to move at all.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah, if I could.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are these guys limited?
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I move through their squares?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, absolutely.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you can't end your movement in one of their squares.
[SPEAKER_00]: So what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna move over to here.
[SPEAKER_00]: So just five, ten feet away.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you go back on the deck.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, so this is just me trying to be elusive.
[SPEAKER_01]: And also, let a crossbowman get it up to the place it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you have the concentration going on that wall of fire.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's right, because it does stay for up to one minute.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, yes, thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so that's the turn.
[SPEAKER_00]: Anish.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, now, you're handling as the DM anything that the captain on the ship does, correct?
[SPEAKER_00]: Correct.
[SPEAKER_00]: And also, of course, anything the enemy does to respond.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Anish, we go back to the top, because we don't re-roll, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: We re-roll.
[SPEAKER_01]: So this is a modification in my game.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the reason I like to re-roll initiative to return is it kind of gives the... A little bit of dynamics.
[SPEAKER_01]: ...dynamics in the way the combat moves.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because if it's just like you and then, you and then, there's no...
[SPEAKER_01]: I suck to the end at this combat.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, good.
[SPEAKER_00]: Go ahead, do you want to... Actually, let me roll first, since you...
[SPEAKER_00]: Eight.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's your highest roll of the day.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, that's not true.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, plus eight, nine, ten, eleven, twelve.
[SPEAKER_00]: Paul, what do you get?
[SPEAKER_00]: Twenty-two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty-four.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll for the sergeant.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wow!
[SPEAKER_00]: I want those dice.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty-two.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that's for the men as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Here's for them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Five.
[SPEAKER_01]: They still beat you.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, you know what it is.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, they might have been.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, they didn't beat me.
[SPEAKER_00]: I got, like, 12.
[SPEAKER_02]: What did they get?
[SPEAKER_00]: They got five, plus whatever.
[SPEAKER_00]: They couldn't beat me.
[SPEAKER_00]: I got 12.
[SPEAKER_00]: They didn't beat me.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, but they have their... What did their...
[SPEAKER_02]: The enemy?
[SPEAKER_02]: The enemy does not beat Jude.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, dang it.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, your first poll, what are you gonna do?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm gonna...
[SPEAKER_02]: Shoot another arrow at him.
[SPEAKER_02]: That guy's down.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, the other guy next to him.
[SPEAKER_02]: That guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And, wait, does he have to hide first because he fired?
[SPEAKER_00]: Like, if he wants to...
[SPEAKER_01]: He has not been exposed.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, he's hidden.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's still on that way.
[SPEAKER_01]: They know where he's shooting at them from, though.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, they can fire at him.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just mean if he gets his extra damage because he's hidden.
[SPEAKER_01]: He gets advantage to shoot at anybody that can't see.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, that's advantage, but does he get the shooting from... You can sneak attack if you have advantage on somebody, or if your enemy is within five feet of an antelope.
[SPEAKER_00]: So he doesn't have to move, but they do know that they're receiving shots from underneath.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, that's about to be an 18.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's an advantage.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: 20.
[SPEAKER_00]: Dude, that's like your third 20 in four rolls.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, do you want a sneak attack?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I just crit him, so that's 8 damage already maxed out.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, 10 damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, so the way it works is this.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you get a crit, all of the dice that you have when you roll is doubled.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, you will get one die eight plus two die six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Doubled is two die eight, four die six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Plus your bonus of plus four.
[SPEAKER_01]: So do you want to sneak attack him?
[SPEAKER_01]: Is there any advantage to not sneak attack him?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, if you had two attacks, you would not use your sneak attack on him.
[SPEAKER_01]: You could use it on somebody else.
[SPEAKER_01]: But he doesn't have that.
[SPEAKER_01]: But he doesn't have two attacks right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he may as well sneak attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's your advantage right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, that'll sneak attack.
[SPEAKER_00]: But keep that in mind.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you had two attacks, then you might keep your second attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: So two die eight, if you want to do that, but I usually like to roll them all at once, so you can use two of those and then four one-sided dies.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yep, this is good.
[SPEAKER_00]: Does he add dexterity bonus?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's plus four.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you don't double that.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's the only one.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that is going to be four, eight, nine, ten, eleven, twelve, thirteen, fourteen, fifteen, plus four is nineteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy drops.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'm gonna make him
[SPEAKER_01]: He's gonna be the D. I can't believe you rolled three 20s in four rolls.
[SPEAKER_00]: You made the E1.
[SPEAKER_02]: The most I've ever rolled, I think, 20s is like two 20s back to back.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you want to move at all?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to re-hide with your bonus action, or do you like what you have?
[SPEAKER_01]: I like what I have.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you're fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: The sergeant basically says to his men, advance on the stairs.
[SPEAKER_00]: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that 30 feet?
[SPEAKER_01]: That's 30 feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that's, let's see, that's going to be 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
[SPEAKER_01]: So the sergeant's here.
[SPEAKER_01]: A1.
[SPEAKER_01]: Man, man.
[SPEAKER_00]: Marine.
[SPEAKER_00]: Dude, these marines are badass.
[SPEAKER_00]: They just took like an initial volley and not a man dropped.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is pretty cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just marine stuff, you know.
[SPEAKER_00]: Have we had a marine go down yet?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, all we've had is one hit.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know what this means?
[SPEAKER_00]: I didn't actually think about this, but that means that whenever a new prince takes over the helm, he probably brings his own men with him.
[SPEAKER_00]: So what I'm guessing is if it's Prince Fairwind, these are Prince Fairwind's men.
[SPEAKER_00]: So we're going to have to fight through Prince Fairwind's men, which is fine, but that also means that he's gone evil?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, it means that him, his island, and all of his troops are compromised.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or Italy is compromised until you can make them surrender.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, it's not like chaos.
[SPEAKER_00]: Chaos, you gotta kill them until the bitter end.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so Jude, you're left there.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You haven't gone yet though, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I did.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, no, you're right.
[SPEAKER_00]: I haven't gone yet.
[SPEAKER_02]: You have not gone yet.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I can only go 30 feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
[SPEAKER_01]: These guys move forward.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're all chill wall.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Dodging, basically.
[SPEAKER_00]: And this is my wall of fire.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's your wall of fire.
[SPEAKER_01]: These three guys, actually these four guys can fire on those hobgoblins or they can fire up into there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wait, they're not hobgoblins, are they?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Really?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like we actually see them as hobgoblins?
[SPEAKER_01]: They're not men.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, shit.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you can see their red faces.
[SPEAKER_01]: Weird.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, well then maybe Lord Fairwind's been taken captive.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anyway, cool, fire over here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, who's shooting those guys?
[SPEAKER_00]: Jules, since you're rolling 320s, why don't you roll... Four people, two on each of these.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You want me to just roll 320?
[SPEAKER_00]: There's another 20.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do two on that guy, and then one on... Two on that guy, two on that guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fourteen plus three is a 17.
[SPEAKER_01]: One hit on that guy, you will call B2.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that does one die ten plus one.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you die ten.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's see if he's still up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Two, three points of damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's up.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then two on that guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty.
[SPEAKER_01]: So two die ten.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, one's a twenty, one's a one.
[SPEAKER_01]: One's a hit with a double, so that's two die ten plus one point of damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that is seven, eight points of damage on B1.
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes down.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want me to get you another pencil?
[SPEAKER_00]: Looks like that one eraser is kind of getting a little frayed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, we go through pencils.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's five 20s and seven rolls.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's what?
[SPEAKER_02]: That's five 20s and eight rolls.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I can actually identify them as kobolds?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I thought you said hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_00]: The red face is given away.
[SPEAKER_00]: Kobolds are, like... Yeah, kobolds are, yeah, they would have been, like, dying even faster.
[SPEAKER_00]: So these are hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_02]: Really weird.
[SPEAKER_02]: What the fuck?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so is it my turn?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: So... Oh, wait.
[SPEAKER_01]: These guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: Attack.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, how many...?
[SPEAKER_01]: They are gonna be shooting at these two.
[SPEAKER_01]: They get to shoot two each.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: On this guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: 15, 18, that's one hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's an A1.
[SPEAKER_00]: Tin-sided?
[SPEAKER_01]: Actually, it's on this guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tin-sided plus one point of damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: So three points of damage, and we're gonna make this guy A2.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's got three of them, and I'll roll two more.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thirteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thirteen, that would be sixteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: That is a miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's a miss?
[SPEAKER_01]: That's a miss.
[SPEAKER_00]: And that's a hit?
[SPEAKER_01]: That's a hit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Seven, eight points of damage, so that is twelve points of damage on him.
[SPEAKER_00]: And yeah, so that's their move.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so my move...
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to try to keep up the shield wall.
[SPEAKER_00]: So it's 5, 10, 15, 20, 25, 30.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I can go there and still cast, correct?
[SPEAKER_00]: Correct.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so I will.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you stay with the Marines.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'm just...
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't think that I can move the wall.
[SPEAKER_00]: Correct?
[SPEAKER_00]: I can't move it around.
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: The wall's where it's at.
[SPEAKER_00]: They have to retreat from the wall, but I don't have to move it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or they get burned.
[SPEAKER_00]: But at the same time, I don't know that I want to cast anything.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think, like, it seems like we've got this issue well in hand.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I ready an action with my wand, and if anybody casts a spell, can I respond to that?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I mean, that's a perfect radiation.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically, you're looking around, and if you see a spellcaster or anything, you can use your wand on them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you're just kind of like moving up like this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Staying with the troops, going, I think we got this, at least at the initial wall.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: Their turn.
[SPEAKER_01]: This hobgoblin moves to here.
[SPEAKER_01]: This one moves to here.
[SPEAKER_01]: This one goes one, two, three.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's like, I'm getting the hell out of Dodge.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he runs down.
[SPEAKER_01]: These guys move backwards.
One, two, three.
[SPEAKER_01]: Out of sight.
[SPEAKER_01]: They do not end their turn within the area of effect, so they're not.
[SPEAKER_01]: The guys inside this area, however, fire down on the Marines.
[SPEAKER_01]: So here is the first shot.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, we don't have lower levels listed here, correct?
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't see them.
[SPEAKER_01]: But if you attack them, I will put that in there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, gotcha.
[SPEAKER_01]: First attack on this guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: Second attack on this guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty and eleven.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eleven plus three is fourteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: First attack on this guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: These guys.
[SPEAKER_00]: These two guys... Are you rolling two because it's a disadvantage?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a disadvantage because they're dodgy, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, that's right.
[SPEAKER_01]: On this guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: First attack, this guy attacks him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy attacks him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Crossbows.
[SPEAKER_01]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: Three guys in here.
[SPEAKER_01]: One guy attacks this guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Misses.
[SPEAKER_01]: Another guy attacks that guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty and a nine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Miss on this guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Two attacks.
[SPEAKER_00]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you understand rules?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_00]: Even though it's a 20, he's rolling disadvantage, so he has to take a lesser one.
[SPEAKER_01]: These guys are basically with their shields.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what's happening is all these bolts start raining down from the fortifications.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, you guys are basically protecting each other and themselves and moving forward as they go.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So...
[SPEAKER_01]: The sergeant's shouting orders.
[SPEAKER_00]: I need to be ready to drop that wall even if they beat me for a niche.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, I don't know how I could do that because if the sergeant wants to move these guys like it seems, like we're aggressively maneuvering, I need to be able to drop the wall.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I don't know how I could...
[SPEAKER_00]: Declare that to the DM?
[SPEAKER_00]: That I'm just prepared to drop concentration?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I think what you can say is if you want to have your action ready, you would say it to me, my action is ready such that when the first man hits the wall, I drop it.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you have to have an action ready for that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I don't think the first guy is going to hit the wall, so if the sergeant pushes up, I'm just going to drop it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Have your action ready.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so we'll wait until I start.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know that I haven't rolled yet.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm just trying to be realistic.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I understand.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so I think that round is finished.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: And hopefully we have about a hundred plus Marine Marine off the boat.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm starting to get on the dock.
[SPEAKER_02]: On the ass down the quay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, Nish.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pier.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ten.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fourteen for Paul.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thirteen plus four, seventeen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Seventeen for Jude.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll for the sergeant and the men.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nine, ten, eleven.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is for these guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: That actually works, son.
[SPEAKER_00]: Seventeen, eighteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: So they get to go first.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So my flame wall is still up, but I do get to still kind of...it works out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Attacks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Three guys on that guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: First attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: 20 and a 14.
[SPEAKER_01]: 14, 17, that's a hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll make that guy be one.
[SPEAKER_01]: Damage is...
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two points of damage on B1.
[SPEAKER_00]: Skims his high shoulder where he's not covered by the shield of his armor.
[SPEAKER_01]: Usually when I do this for computers it's easier, but you know.
[SPEAKER_01]: B1 takes two.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you usually do this on a laptop?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And actually I have an application where I would automate all this, but I think it's nicer to roll the dice in a lot of ways.
[SPEAKER_01]: Next guy on him, 15, 11, 14 is a miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: Next guy on A1, 10, 5, miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: Two up here, this guy on that guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: 14 is a hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll make him C1 and the damage is... Where's the 10 sided guy?
[SPEAKER_01]: 3, 4 on C1.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy on him.
[SPEAKER_01]: 13, 16.
[SPEAKER_01]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that a miss?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, that's a miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's wearing a scam mail.
[SPEAKER_01]: Guy underneath on him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: Next guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So...
[SPEAKER_01]: They've done their thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jude, you're next.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, I yell...
[SPEAKER_00]: Forward, and I dissipate my wall.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, does that actually take the full action for me?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, it doesn't take an action at all.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't have to ready an action if you don't want to.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, if you were going to ready the action and wait for the guy... Well, what I would like to do is I'm still cautious for a mage to show, so I want to ready any action, but I just yell forward and I dissipate my wall, so I drop the concentration, and can I ready an action with my wand still if there's a mage that shows himself?
[SPEAKER_00]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, so I do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: And also, what I allow people to do is
[SPEAKER_01]: If you want to move...
[SPEAKER_00]: I would like to be able to stay with the group.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you can stay with the group as you walk behind.
[SPEAKER_00]: If the group for any reason doesn't move, then I don't move.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so Jude is gone.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know how to do battle tactics.
[SPEAKER_01]: Paul.
[SPEAKER_02]: My turn?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, let's move me up here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so you want to break cover and run up behind the men.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so you break cover.
[SPEAKER_01]: Going from prone to standing takes half your movement.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that 15?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like half of standard movement, which would be 30?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what you do is you can crawl to there.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then if you dash... You can stand, which would take 25 of your movement.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can go 5 to here.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then if you want a bonus action dash, you can go 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 to there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I'll dash.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you use bonus action dash to there.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then you still, because he's a... You still have an action.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want ready an action?
[SPEAKER_01]: Ready an action.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or do you want to fire on one of these guys that's firing down on you?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll ready.
[SPEAKER_00]: Real quick question.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can he see anybody once I drop the wall?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm gonna ready the action.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what does that mean?
[SPEAKER_01]: He basically, how are you gonna ready it?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm just looking around waiting for... You see guys firing at you guys up in here.
[SPEAKER_00]: See like for me, so ready and action has to be kind of specific.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm saying wand is ready if a mage or any magic appears... Then I'll open up on one of them if I can down there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you fire into one of the, now this guy has a plus five in the AC, for the AC.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because he's actually in a lower slot.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, you fire on that guy, it is, the attack roll is a 19, so you have to roll at least a 19.
[SPEAKER_01]: For you it would be a 13 to hit one of those guys.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ten.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your bolt knocks off the wall, but you basically come up to here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Um...
[SPEAKER_01]: Back to the... One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_01]: The sergeant's gonna come to here.
[SPEAKER_00]: So is he leading away?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then we have nine guys.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four... Do you need to list the ones that are wounded?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'll do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let me put them in.
[SPEAKER_01]: So...
[SPEAKER_01]: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it will be all there.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to make this B1.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll make this C1.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will make A1 be right here.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then, that looks right, and then the archers are gonna go, see, so that's one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Archer, archer, archer, archer, archer, one, two, three, four, five.
[SPEAKER_00]: You just have them kind of ban out?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, well, yeah, like this.
[SPEAKER_01]: One,
[SPEAKER_01]: Five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then me and Paul will kind of slide.
[SPEAKER_01]: Paul isn't going to be able to do it, but you will be able to do it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Kind of slide into the middle.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's here with figures.
[SPEAKER_01]: For sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Paul is gonna be right there though.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, and one, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_01]: These guys will be able to fire on enemies.
[SPEAKER_01]: These three guys fire on the guys on the wall.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jude, you do it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is it gonna be two and... Just roll three dice and two on this guy, one on that guy, and...
[SPEAKER_01]: The green one's on that guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is a 17, 20.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's a 16.
[SPEAKER_01]: Two hits on that guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so...
[SPEAKER_01]: Seven, eight plus...
[SPEAKER_01]: So that guy goes away.
[SPEAKER_01]: So B2 goes down.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then do I need to roll for this side?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let me... Yeah, I'll roll.
[SPEAKER_00]: Take B2 down.
[SPEAKER_00]: How many guys do I have?
[SPEAKER_00]: Three?
[SPEAKER_00]: Three.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And 20 is the only hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Miss, miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, but that's a 2 die 10, and this guy is gonna be...
[SPEAKER_01]: He will be D3, 2 die 10.
[SPEAKER_01]: Three... That's 11 plus 1 is 12 points of damage, and that's it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, I think back to the top and we'll wait for Jade to come back and it's re-rolling-ish.
[SPEAKER_00]: I like that idea because I do know like whenever I've DMed, it's kind of like, oh yeah, you're screwed.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're like the last one.
[SPEAKER_00]: It makes it so much more exciting.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, well because it changes up the potential dynamic.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like I was the last one last time, but now I'm the first one.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it's like, it makes Pursuit even more interesting, because it's like, you win initiative, and you really book it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I did hear one guy said, he suggested, if you're trying not to bog down combat, which combat can obviously take, like you said, hours, he said, allow it to be with their role, and obviously they get to do their decks, but it was something like...
[SPEAKER_00]: He was saying, like, if you wanted to roll once for the group, right, so once for the enemy, once for the group, that you could allow the group to take their shots based off of their dex bonus, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: So that the faster members of the group get to shoot... That actually sounds pretty interesting.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, get to shoot earlier than the slower members of the group.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would consider that.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, I have to tell you that...
[SPEAKER_01]: That would be a lot of animosity between characters if you let somebody roll in there.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know I have characters that basically live or die based on what their initiative is, and if they are stuck with bad rolls by somebody else, they'd be like, ah!
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, they'd be like, why do I have alert?
[SPEAKER_00]: Why did I waste time with alert?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, go ahead.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll your initiative.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so this is Jude, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Mm-hmm.
[SPEAKER_01]: Two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Two plus four, six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, roll for the sergeant and the men.
[SPEAKER_00]: Two.
[SPEAKER_00]: Three.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So as we're climbing the stairs...
[SPEAKER_00]: These are the, um...
[SPEAKER_00]: I've got ones.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nineteen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oof.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Um...
[SPEAKER_00]: Shoot, what was I gonna say?
[SPEAKER_00]: I like how we did this.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, at least.
[SPEAKER_00]: I like the gaming part of it in the sense that, like, you know, rowboats are away, we're taking over that, like, you know, like, I gave just enough information that it was like, the guy was like, okay, triggered.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cause I'm all like, I was thinking to myself, I was like, if I go into the harbor and it's like, and they've got some kind of like ballista or something that they can like,
[SPEAKER_00]: Waste ships right in the middle of the harbor.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm all, fuck that.
[SPEAKER_00]: You would be able to see the blisses.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, but I'm all like, even if it's a fire ship or if it's catapults with flaming shit, I'm all, fuck that, dude.
[SPEAKER_00]: I wanna, like I said, I'll kiss the ring and apologize later.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're up, Jules.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sorry, you let me roll for the guys.
[SPEAKER_00]: It sucked.
[SPEAKER_02]: Jude, you need to lock in today, bro.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I mean, like, I did do a firewall.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've killed maybe more people than you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Only because you're a magic user, dude.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys just sit in corners.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, just roll.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fireball.
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll for yourself.
[SPEAKER_00]: Rolling in.
[SPEAKER_02]: Keep going high.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Two.
[SPEAKER_02]: Another nat 20.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Firing.
[SPEAKER_01]: These guys fire on one on you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, shit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, what's your AC?
[SPEAKER_00]: 16?
[SPEAKER_00]: Because the whole group went forward.
[SPEAKER_02]: Uh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Team, you are hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: You take six, seven points of damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Crossbow quarrels aren't no joke.
[SPEAKER_01]: One attack on this guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nineteen, it's a hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: For five, he is going to be Archer one, no, I'm gonna make him...
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm gonna make him A20, I think.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that was, shows five, six points of damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then, on this guy, 17 hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh wait, don't they have disadvantage?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because it's a shield wall?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, they're not behind guys now.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, okay, okay, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, it's because it's the archer.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, gotcha, gotcha.
[SPEAKER_01]: A2.
[SPEAKER_00]: Does he drop, or is he starting?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, no, he's not dropping yet.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that was three, four points of damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's one guy up here still.
[SPEAKER_01]: He fires down on that archer.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twelve, fifteen, miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: Three guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: One guy fires on that guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eight, miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: Next guy, seventeen hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is a three.
[SPEAKER_01]: Takes eight points of damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Over here, guys fire on this front rank.
[SPEAKER_01]: On him, here's the attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: Don't they have shields, though?
[SPEAKER_01]: They do.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're a bonus.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're right.
[SPEAKER_01]: I should do two.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Three, miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: That guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Dude, these Marines are so cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nineteen, sixteen.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think the thirteen misses though, doesn't it?
[SPEAKER_01]: Thirteen plus three.
[SPEAKER_01]: It is a miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: They have 17 AC.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just barely a miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so that misses.
[SPEAKER_01]: It went through the shield.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then that was the hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jude is six.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's me?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Which tower are we taking more fire from?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, this guy, two guys got hit over here, one guy got hit over here.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's a guy that's up on top, alive there.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I just mean taking, do I have a purpose?
[SPEAKER_01]: There are four people shooting from here, two people shooting from here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so I'm gonna go from over here, and I'm gonna launch Fireball now.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a sphere, so I can go below.
[SPEAKER_01]: True, true.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so what I want to do is I want to put it like right basically like four feet on the inside.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a 20-foot sphere, so it's 5, 10, 15, 20.
[SPEAKER_01]: You want to blow it through the windows, but also on this guy as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, exactly, and below if I can.
[SPEAKER_00]: Blow it through the windows too, below.
[SPEAKER_00]: So shoot, fireball.
[SPEAKER_00]: So it's 150 feet, I'm easily within range.
[SPEAKER_00]: Bright streak of flame flows each creature in a 20-foot ray of sphere.
[SPEAKER_00]: Dexterity save or 8d6 fire.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I don't think it's ore, I think they take full or half.
[SPEAKER_00]: Damage, I'm going to fail save half as much, so it's 8d6.
[SPEAKER_00]: So the guys in that tower will need to make a Dexterity saving throw, and I will get 8d6.
[SPEAKER_00]: So 4, 5, 6.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, this is what I'm going to say.
[SPEAKER_01]: The guys in the tower have partial cover.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what that means is they're going to have a bonus to their saving throw based on that.
[SPEAKER_01]: They will have a plus two on their saving throw because they are behind the window.
[SPEAKER_01]: The guy on top is not going to have that.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you roll the 8d6 for damage, I'll roll the saving throw so the guys inside three of them get a plus two.
[SPEAKER_01]: So this is 66, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: So this is 5, 9, 14, 15, 16.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll those two more.
[SPEAKER_01]: 16 plus 7, 23.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is the guy on top, his saving throw.
[SPEAKER_01]: He needs a 15 because he's got a plus 1.
[SPEAKER_01]: 12, he does not make it.
[SPEAKER_00]: He burns.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then the two guys get a plus two.
[SPEAKER_01]: The guys below, there are three of them.
[SPEAKER_01]: So they get plus three, because they get a plus one for their dex.
[SPEAKER_01]: They get a plus one for dex, plus two.
[SPEAKER_01]: So they need to roll 13s.
[SPEAKER_01]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_00]: Burn, burn, burn.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: The tower is engulfed in flames.
[SPEAKER_01]: I am Tim.
[SPEAKER_01]: You hear the screams.
[SPEAKER_01]: A foreign hobgoblins scream.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're like jumping out a little bit.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's no windows to jump out of, but this guy does flame and then fall onto the beach, his body moldering right there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, and I assume you're going to continue to march with the guys as you go on.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, continue to march with the guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will mark off the third.
[SPEAKER_00]: I did mark off my firewall, by the way, and so I'm marking off one of my three bubbles.
[SPEAKER_00]: Don't shoot, let them burn.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, don't shoot, let them burn.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Saving Private Ryan.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, Paul, your turn.
[SPEAKER_02]: Awesome.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's move in with the rest of the group.
[SPEAKER_02]: So what I'm going to say is you're going to come to here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, and as they move up, you're gonna move up with it, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, that's what I wanted.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you move to there, you got an action, a bonus action, what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: There's still two guys here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'll take a shot again.
[SPEAKER_01]: Plus five AC, a 19, you have to roll a 19, you need to roll, get a 13 to be able to get it.
[SPEAKER_01]: 12.
[SPEAKER_01]: You get it in the window.
[SPEAKER_01]: The guy misses.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, their turn.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sergeant moves to here.
[SPEAKER_01]: And let's see about this.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_00]: These fuckers are from the marsh.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or the salt marsh.
[SPEAKER_02]: Have you ever played on Omaha Beach with a flamethrower in Hala Guestad?
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh, well, yeah, but I don't know if I played on the initial wave.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think I've always done it one wave that were like...
[SPEAKER_02]: I've only ever done it once as a flamethrower, where I got in, and I got into one of those small, silly little bunkers.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know what, I have moved through the trenches as a flamethrower.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, and I have torn.
[SPEAKER_02]: But there was two guys, and they were poking out of the doorway into the trench, shooting their guys, and I went, and I went, and I torched it, and it burned.
[SPEAKER_00]: I got somebody in a bunker, and then I got somebody moving in the open area of the trenches, and I could see their head, and I just grazed it right above, but it totally hit them in the head.
[SPEAKER_00]: That was all you could hear.
[SPEAKER_02]: I wish the bunkers on Omaha Beach weren't so late.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because they're like those silly little one-man poke out of a little hole in the roof of the- No, there's a couple big bunkers.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, like two on the entire beach.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I spare a quick look back?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I at least see, like, Marines pouring, like, you know, over the ship and, like, way down in the dark?
[SPEAKER_01]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is that what I see?
[SPEAKER_00]: They're coming out of the water.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just want to make sure we're not being screwed, and it's like, you know, he's all...
[SPEAKER_01]: The Marines are not getting off the boat.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're not getting off the boat?
[SPEAKER_01]: And, in fact, you see combat happening on the ship.
[SPEAKER_00]: On the ship?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_01]: And...
[SPEAKER_01]: There are creatures that are coming out of the water onto the docks, and there's real combat happening there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, all of there.
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll let them do their everything.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's got his hands full.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, wait, wait, wait.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, correct me if I'm wrong.
[SPEAKER_00]: There was two long boats with 15 H, so 30 guys, and Gouge was one of them, was hitting that one...
[SPEAKER_00]: The southern lighthouse.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, southern lighthouse.
[SPEAKER_00]: We come around the corner, we have 20 guys and me and Paul, so 22.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you're saying that there's like a hundred...
[SPEAKER_01]: So 50 guys are off the boat.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: 200 guys are on the boat.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: And there's like mayhem and just fighting going on.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like when I glance behind you...
[SPEAKER_01]: There are hundreds of creatures.
[SPEAKER_01]: On the docks and trying to scale the boat.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, but when you say the docks, you mean like out here?
[SPEAKER_00]: Out there, where the boat is.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are they massing?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, no, they're not massing there yet.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're not massing there yet.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: But there's battle happening out on that ship.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I'm glad that I blew that tower up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, wow.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have six archers.
[SPEAKER_01]: They can fire on the hobgoblins that are in front.
[SPEAKER_01]: They fire.
[SPEAKER_01]: So Jude, you see that happening.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nobody else has seen it yet.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you want to roll all the attacks, or what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: I roll three, you roll three.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, for the archers?
[SPEAKER_02]: Or wait?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I...
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so am I allowed to talk, regardless of where I land in, like, you know, the scale of...
[SPEAKER_01]: So, the thing is, this is about who gets to roll the dice.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is not...
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, you can utter something.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: But it's... We're not done with the turn yet.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're not done with the turn yet.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so why don't you just roll the dice, Jay?
[SPEAKER_01]: So six.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are four targets.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll six dice and we'll distribute the attacks.
[SPEAKER_01]: And there are four hobgoblins that are available.
[SPEAKER_01]: They have an AC of 16, so you need to roll at least a 13 to hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: 120, 118, so do the crit first.
[SPEAKER_01]: Two 10-sided dice, plus one.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you got both.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that is 13, 14 points of damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: That guy does not go down, but he's severely wounded.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, actually, he does go down.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's one of the burnt ones.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then... One die for the other guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: One die for the other guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two points of damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: These guys can't be seen, so they can't be attacked.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think that's it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so new round, roll a niche.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, how do you allow yelling out, speaking?
[SPEAKER_01]: You can say something in combat, and it doesn't cost anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you can't give a speech.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, of course not.
[SPEAKER_00]: So what I want to do is, even before I yell, I'm going to yell, Paul, the ship.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm moving towards the ship and I'm going to say Sarge, secure the landing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like the landing meaning this area.
[SPEAKER_00]: Would that be the correct term?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I yell for the Sarge to secure the landing because I'm pretty sure everybody here is dead.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's just guys here and here.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's three guys over there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And there's maybe a couple of guys over here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I'm going to say secure.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, you see one of the guys running.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right, so I'm gonna yell for the Sarge, secure the landing, and I'm gonna yell for Paul, and we're gonna bowl back down.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna say the ship, cause we gotta like, we can't let the guys just get fucked up.
[SPEAKER_00]: And if it's like sea creatures and shit, that's like a sailor's worst nightmare.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, even if they're fighting great.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll go with you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you say, Paul, the ship!
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then turn around.
[SPEAKER_01]: So roll an itch.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Six plus four.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I have one plus four, so I have five.
[SPEAKER_01]: And Paul, you have, what, ten?
[SPEAKER_00]: Now do we still want to roll for the Sarge, or you got the Sarge and she's going independent?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I'll roll for the Sarge.
[SPEAKER_00]: He gives a twenty.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it secures the landing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so basically the marines swing out and start going that way.
[SPEAKER_01]: And they're going to swing that way and start dealing with them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Effectively, the combat for you that way is over.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Except that there are two guys here.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: But we are moving, so in whatever speed, a single maroon.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I am no longer following the group, so...
[SPEAKER_01]: So Jude's here, Paul's here.
[SPEAKER_01]: I am going to say these guys cannot fire, so they're basically waiting for you to do whatever you're going to do.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's fine, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like if we show up in the open as we run across the sand, they get an opportunity.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Paul, you're first.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going with him to the shit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you're in front of me.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're right here and you want an ish.
[SPEAKER_01]: You want to just wait to see what Jude does?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: I assume we're both going... Yeah, I yelled and pointed and I said, Sarge, secure the lane.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, alright, let's dash.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to dash down this way?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So Paul begins taking off this way.
[SPEAKER_01]: So 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
[SPEAKER_01]: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
[SPEAKER_01]: You want to go to there?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then don't you still get to do something because that's your special...
[SPEAKER_01]: He's got an action.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, dodge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you're dodging.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is it my turn?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or do they get to go?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, you get to go.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, that's right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I'm just going to dash.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'm going to- One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, can I use my shield?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, because it's a reaction.
[SPEAKER_01]: If I had to.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_00]: And if anybody is going to hit me, I'm going to use my shield.